today I want to talk to you about how
connecting as a whole with the German
language
the very first language I learned myself
made all the difference
at the ripe age of 15 I had been
learning English French and Latin at
school and I told myself it was about
time to learn another language German
which my family constantly talked about
and that's what I did I just got a were
a dusty grammar book that I found at my
grandmother's place and I started to
leave through it and then going through
the exercises yes exactly
exercises that book was full of grammar
that was focused on grammar and that
reminded me of how I learned led and
that was a mistake that I was not aware
of because I was approaching German
intellectually just intellectually with
my mind what you have to do is not only
to connect with the language
intellectually which is great but also
with your mind with your body you have
to connect it emotionally that makes all
the difference because in the long run
you will need other things not just your
mind to keep walking down the language
path
[Music]
so after a few weeks of painfully
leafing through the book and trying to
move forward I told myself this is never
going to happen I'm not going to learn
German but then a lucky turn of events
happened and I actually ended up buying
another course which was more modern
more colorful more engaging and overall
it was really cool I started to use this
this book and it made all the difference
within a few weeks I actually realized
that there were other ways of
approaching language learning material
and I found out about my bi-directional
translation course so I started using
translation to understand and figure out
the basic patterns of a language that
gave me an enormous boost I started
connecting not only with the pages but
also with the language and with myself
and the combination of these three
things really made a huge difference in
the short as well as in the long run so
after finding this cool course and after
finding a method to worked wonder for me
I started making time for the language
when I woke up the very first thing that
came to my mind was not cookies or
breakfast it was German and
automatically I started to plan and make
the time to learn it every single day
even if I went to school even if I was
very busy that made a huge difference
and what I did is that every time that I
completed a task I spent one hour with
German I always made sure that I had a
logbook with me where I put all the
entries every single day looking back
every month or every two months
I actually saw how much ground I had
covered and that gave me extra
motivation to move forward
moving from a merely intellectual to an
intellectual and emotional connection
with the language was huge progress but
one thing was still missing and that was
the human factor so it turned out that
two years into learning German I met a
native German speaker when I was in a
summer camp in Sardinia and the cool
thing about this is that years after
meeting for the first time I established
a very profound relationship a bond with
her and we started exchanging letters
and we did this for years and the
connection I developed with her with the
letters themselves it really made a huge
difference in me wanting to pursue
German for life not just for two or
three years I was not aware of that at
the time but that encounter those
exchanges those words those letters were
all an emotional or a word per se and
those were words really make a
difference in you walking down the
language path and getting to your
destination but there are many other
rewards not just emotional rewards their
intellectual rewards for example the
first time did you understand the scene
of a movie after learning the language
for a little bit the first time that you
go to the shop around the corner and you
get to have a strike a conversation and
a meaningful one of that with a person
and then you have what I call
existential rewards and in short
experiences for example you travel
abroad you start tasting seeing smelling
but not just you go into the country but
also having native speakers coming to
you you can host
native speakers you can have dinner with
them you can go around the city these
are all form of rewards that keep you
going and they will keep you motivated
in down the language path
the bottom line of it all is that you
have to see language-learning
like a holistic organic live experience
it is an intellectual challenge but it's
also an emotional journey and ultimately
it's a set of life-changing experiences
so I got two questions for you the first
one is have you ever tried to learn a
language but given up after a few weeks
can you tell me why that happened and
the second thing is what do you think
are the most important rules of thumb
for you to stay on track and to stay
motivated I'm very eager to know your
opinion in the comment section below so
try to write as much as you can if you
want to know more about how to stay on
track please click on the description
box below the video and you will read a
ton of other additional information
[Music]